unsolo i'm captain in the Millennium
Falcon Chewie here tells me you're
looking for passage to the Alderaan
system isn't be if it's a fast ship fast
ship you've never heard of the
Millennium Falcon should I have hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my non-spoilery solo a Star Wars story
review I had a chance to see the movie
I will rank all of my favorite Star Wars
films at the end of this - I always try
to rear ank the list every time I see a
new Star Wars film so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos special
bonus - because Jon Favreau was at the
premiere and he's the showrunner for the
new live-action Star Wars TV series he
gave some details about that so I'll add
that video at the end of this - I was
just as fascinated to see what the movie
looked like given all the stuff that has
been happening in the last year with the
Star Wars franchise there was a line of
one of those earlier trailers when Han
is piloting the Millennium Falcon with
this tricky maneuver and they almost
completely wipe out and he says it's
fine everything's fine so I feel like
that's a good way to describe the movie
in a good way in a bad way
it's just fine so we'll try to provide
some context for that but there is a lot
going on in this in-between time period
between big saga films probably the most
interesting thing coming out of the
movie is the feeling that they're
actually genuinely trying to create a
story universe set during this earlier
time period so you have to remember that
Solo takes place between Revenge of the
Sith in a new hope there's a lot of
stuff going on in the galaxy they don't
necessarily address but hint at and I
think we're all hoping that the Obi one
movie that they've been talking about
for a long time isn't just vapor where
they will end up making that so I'll
address that when I talk more about
spoilers because I do think that they go
to links to try and create more context
for what's going on and set up plot
details that they could pay off in a
potential obi-wan movie purely on a
surface level if you have kids and
you're taking them to see the movie or
you're taking your families or friends
it's a totally serviceable summer Star
Wars movie it's a little lifeless during
some parts it doesn't quite achieve the
thrills or the heights that the newer
Disney saga films have achieved Donal
Glover's Lando is probably one of the
best
characters and actor performances to
walk out of the film though so if you
wonder why a lot of people are suddenly
talking about a Lando spin-off movie now
that if they choose to continue this Han
Solo storyline that they set up in this
movie that Lando should be the character
that they follow just because it feels
like much more fertile territory than
trying to go back to the Han Solo well
there'll be all kinds of think pieces
about cognitive dissonance at fans
watching this younger version of Han
Solo in Alden Ehrenreich scare achter in
how he's not quite doing an impression
of Harrison Ford so if you can reconcile
some of those differences there are some
genuinely enjoyable moments during the
film but I don't think the film itself
had anything particularly special to say
like things that had to be done like
this is mostly a movie done because
people like the Han Solo character and
they wanted to do a film with some
spin-off characters he just happens to
be one of the biggest ones in the
history of Star Wars so that's why they
gave him the film surprising detail -
Lawrence Kasdan revealed that he had
actually started developing the Han Solo
spin-off movie before the Disney buyout
deal several years ago Ron Howard is a
totally serviceable director you'll
understand why they called him in and
not somebody else because he was able to
bring it on time and on budget after
Phil Lord and Chris Miller had shot
everything up to like the last couple
weeks of principal photography they
saying about 70% of it is Ron Howard so
it's mostly Ron Howard's film so once
you have a chance to see the movie and
get an overall feel for it you'll
probably understand why Kathleen Kennedy
and the Star Wars powers-that-be
were reticent to let Phil Lord and Chris
Miller just completely improvised
everything that was going on during the
film because I feel like even in his
performance Alden Ehrenreich is trying
to do his version of Han Solo like I
said rather than doing an impression of
Harrison Ford because his han Solo is
probably the most iconic film character
next to Luke Skywalker in the history of
Star Wars like he's just such an
important character to so many people
that I feel like The Improv version of
Star Wars would have been even worse
received than what you might hear about
people complaining about coming out of
this film but like I said is a totally
serviceable film but not really special
in the grand scheme of things so I do
rank it
little bit lower on my list of Star Wars
films so that's why I think when you
hear people talk about sequels to this
movie they do not bring young Han Solo
back they bring Lando back talking about
the actual characters the performances
themselves Alden Ehrenreich like I said
cognitive dissonance you can see like
Harrison Ford behind the scenes patting
him on the back like hey you know good
try this is amazing I feel like that's
what most people will come away thinking
about like okay this is a version of Han
Solo the new actor that they have
playing Chewbacca did a great job he was
in last Jedi as that character but he
didn't have a whole lot to do during
that movie probably the most important
character was the Millennium Falcon they
actually treat it like a character in
the film like you would expect it was
fun to see it from this perspective
given everything that we know about it
so far so there was a certain
fascination aspect and paying that off
Emilia Clarke's performance as Kira was
totally serviceable I liked her better
in Game of Thrones but if you're talking
about her in big films this was much
better than Emilia Clarke during
Terminator Genisys Donald Glover like I
said probably the best character actor
pairing performance to come out of the
film so hopefully they'll bring him back
during this supposed obi-wan film if it
isn't actually vaporware
I've already gushed about l3 great
performance Paul Bettany right out of
infinity war funny to see him pop up in
another Disney franchise his dryden Voss
character was totally serviceable he's a
great actor but he wasn't somebody that
had a lot of high expectations for so we
can talk more about that during spoilers
there are a couple big surprises during
the film but most of that is in service
of world-building
in this rogue one period between Episode
three and episode four Woody Harrelson's
character also someone that I didn't
have a lot of expectations about going
into the film but I've always been a fan
of his work I'm a little more excited to
see what he does in the venom movie
because I think he's playing a bigger
character and that he liked Paul Bettany
great actor playing a relatively side
character that we probably will not be
talking about when we get to Episode
nine there were a couple big notable
cameos we can't really talk about them
without getting into spoilers but some
of them were more memorable than others
but taken as a whole the film itself
isn't a complete mess like everybody
thought it was going to be so if you
really like going to see big summer
movies and you have a family or you have
friends that just really like this
universe
I feel like it'll totally be fine but
it's not like missing out on this will
cause you to miss out on important plot
details for episode 9 so if you're
mostly a saga film person you can just
watch those by themselves and then they
have these spin-off movies just to be
fun stories that are also set within the
timeline so we can argue about the
timeline and more specific details when
I post more spoiler videos I'll wait to
do that till the film actually drops in
theaters but what you do have a chance
to see it post your non spoilery
reactions in the comments below here is
my new re-ranking of my favorite Star
Wars films so this is quite a bit
different than after I saw last Jedi
starting with my favorite and working my
way down the list its Empire Strikes
Back no surprise there I feel like most
people's favorite Star Wars film new
hope Return of the Jedi force awakens
rogue one last Jedi which I was actually
much lower on my list then after I first
saw it
Revenge of the Sith Attack of the Clones
solo so you kind of get an idea where
I'm ranking so low compared to other
Star Wars films Phantom Menace then
caravan of courage battle for Endor I
had to put them on the list I don't want
to leave them out very bottom still
holiday special even though it holds a
special place in the fandom like it's so
bad you have to watch it it's like a
rite of passage for Star Wars fans
because this week is more Deadpool
related stuff it's dropping in theaters
be sure to go see that I'll be posting
my Easter eggs and post-credit scenes
all those things later this week once
everybody gets a chance to see it later
tonight we have new flash and then there
are details about the Star Wars TV
series the live-action TV series the jon
favreau has been talking about we're
going to be creating a Star Wars show of
your very own coming down the pipeline
is there anything you can tell us about
that where are you in the production
process where I've written I actually
wrote a lot of the scripts even before I
had the job to be honest with you I
wrote like four to show them what the
show would be and I've been thinking
about doing this show for a long time
it's a part of the timeline that hasn't
been explored yet so it's after it's
about seven years after the Battle of
Yavin so it's like after after after
Return of the Jedi before before 7:00
right and it's all new characters
different planets and so a whole new
piece of but but also fits into the
timeline so as we learn more about that
I'll do a video or two just explaining
what's going on but we won't see any
footage from that till next year so no
worries but click here for my
non-spoilery Deadpool to review and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight